Randy Amos was police chief in Albertville, Alabama, during years when lots of immigrants moved to town. And people in town sometimes did not know what to make of them.
Randy Amos曾担任阿拉巴马州阿尔伯特维尔的警察局长，当时正值大量移民迁入该镇。镇上的人有时不知道该如何看待他们。
I remember I would get calls from people saying, you've got to do something about these Mexicans next door. I'd say, well, what are these Mexicans doing? And they said, well, they're devil worshipers. And I said, what do you mean they're devil worshippers? Well, they're over here killing goats.
我记得我常接到人们的电话说：你得管管隔壁那些墨西哥人。我会问：好吧，那些墨西哥人在做什么呢？他们说：他们是魔鬼崇拜者。我说：你说的魔鬼崇拜者是什么意思？他们说：他们在杀山羊。
And of course, they would hear the cry of a goat when the throat was being cut, which is a bad sound. I agree. But they eat the goat. That was not a satanic ritual that they were going through.
当然，当他们听到山羊被割喉时的哀叫声时，那确实是一种糟糕的声音。我同意。但他们是把山羊吃了。这根本不是什么撒旦仪式。
And so we'd go back to the caller and explain to them, look, these people are not worshipping Satan. I'm sorry that you had to hear the goat cry. But it's not violating any laws or ordinances that we have in existence here in Albertville, Alabama.
所以我们会回电给举报者并向他们解释：看，这些人不是在崇拜撒旦。很抱歉让你听到了山羊的叫声，但这并不违反我们在阿拉巴马州阿尔伯特维尔现行的任何法律或条例。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. This is our second episode about Albertville, Alabama. You don't need to have heard last week's show to understand this one. But just in case you missed it, here's our premise, very quickly.
这是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），我是Ira Glass。这是我们关于阿拉巴马州阿尔伯特维尔的第二集。你不必听过上一周的节目也能理解这一集。但以防你错过了，简单快速地回顾一下我们的前提。
The current attorney general, Jeff Sessions, wants to limit immigration to our country. His views have been instrumental in shaping administration policy. And as we explained in last week's show, his perspective comes from what he saw as a senator from Alabama when undocumented immigrants moved into poultry plants and other jobs around the state into towns like Albertville.
现任司法部长杰夫·塞申斯（Jeff Sessions）想要限制我国的移民。他的观点在塑造政府政策方面起到了关键作用。正如我们在上周节目中所解释的，他的观点源于他作为阿拉巴马州参议员时的所见所闻，当时无证移民迁入了该州的家禽工厂和其他工作岗位，进入了像阿尔伯特维尔这样的城镇。
In just 20 years, Albertville went from being 98% white to more than 1/4 Latino. Basically, there were 15,000 people and then another 6,000 arrived, mostly for jobs in the town's chicken processing plants. There's no official estimate of this, but the people who know the Latino community best say that more than half the Latino adults are living here illegally-- maybe a lot more than half.
在短短20年里，阿尔伯特维尔从一个98%人口为白人的城镇变成了拥有超过1/4拉美裔人口的地方。基本上，在原有1.5万人的基础上又来了6000人，大多是为镇上的鸡肉加工厂工作。虽然没有官方的准确统计，但最了解拉美裔社区的人说，超过半数的拉美裔成年人是非法居住在这里的——甚至可能远不止一半。
In the past, Jeff Sessions has mostly spoken about the effects of those immigrants on jobs and wages-- stuff that we talked about in last week's show. Last week, we stayed inside the chicken plants. But 6,000 new residents, non-white residents, in this little white town-- that also upended things outside the plants, to the point where Albertville became the statewide symbol in Alabama of everything that is wrong with immigration.
过去，杰夫·塞申斯主要谈论的是这些移民对就业和工资的影响——也就是我们上周节目中谈到的内容。上周，我们待在鸡肉工厂里。但是，在这个小小的白人城镇里，6000名新居民——非白人居民——也颠覆了工厂之外的一切，以至于阿尔伯特维尔成为了阿拉巴马州移民问题负面影响的州级象征。
At one point, one of the big national heavy hitters on the immigration issue, Kris Kobach, flew in and declared the city a disaster zone. He wrote, quote, "I have been all over the country fighting this fight, and I have seen the damage done by illegal immigration in cities of every size. But Albertville is in a class by itself." He described a town of mobile home ghettos and a city budget, quote, "thoroughly drained by illegal immigration."
有一次，移民问题上的全国重量级人物克里斯·科巴赫（Kris Kobach）飞到这里，宣布该市为灾区。他写道：我走遍全国处理这个问题，在各种规模的城市都看到了非法移民造成的破坏。但阿尔伯特维尔的情况是独一无二的。他描述了一个拥有移动房屋贫民窟的城镇，以及一个被非法移民彻底掏空的城市预算。
And the story of what really happened is so different from that. It's a mix of small local stuff in neighborhoods and in traffic-- traffic is actually a big deal-- and the local stuff sort of colliding with big national political forces that blew into town like a hurricane and reshaped how Albertville saw itself for a while-- but only for a while. And now, with the distance of a few years, it is actually possible to figure out the truth of what those 6,000 newcomers did to Albertville-- what they did to crime rates and schools and property values.
而事实真相与此大相径庭。这是一个关于街区琐事和交通问题——交通其实是个大问题——以及当地琐事与飓风般席卷小镇的全国性政治力量相碰撞的故事，这些力量在一段时间内重塑了阿尔伯特维尔对自身的看法，但只是暂时的。现在，隔着几年的距离，我们实际上已经可以搞清楚那6000名新来者到底给阿尔伯特维尔带来了什么——他们对犯罪率、学校和房产价值究竟产生了什么影响。
It's possible to say what having them in town really cost taxpayers. And we're going to get to all that today. My coworker, Miki Meek, and I have interviewed over 100 people for this. Miki is co-hosting these two hours with me. Stay with us.
现在可以确定他们对纳税人真正的成本是多少了。今天我们将深入探讨这一切。我和我的同事Miki Meek为此采访了超过100人。Miki将与我共同主持这两个小时的节目。请继续收听。
Act one-- Fender Benders and Christmas Lights. So in the early years, back in the '90's, as people slowly realized that newcomers have arrived and there are lots of them, the problem with the newcomers isn't the stuff that you usually hear about when people talk about immigration. It's not jobs or wages or the cost to taxpayers. It's other stuff, neighbor to neighbor stuff, cars and yards and dead goats.
第一幕——追尾事故与圣诞彩灯。在90年代初，随着人们慢慢意识到新来者已经到来且人数众多，关于新来者的问题并不是人们通常在讨论移民时听到的那些东西。不是工作、工资或纳税人的成本。而是其他琐事，邻里之间的摩擦，车子、院子和死掉的山羊。
The first immigrants to move to town were single Mexican men living together in trailer parks. They weren't in the neighborhoods yet. So unless you worked at a poultry plant, your first meaningful encounter with one of the newcomers was probably in your car. The number of hit-and-runs more than doubled in Albertville once immigrants moved to town. And everyone we met seemed to have a story of someone in their family getting into a wreck or fender bender. Again, here's Randy Amos, the police chief in Albertville back in the '90's, and Benny Womack, his successor.
第一批搬到镇上的移民是住在一起的单身墨西哥男性，他们当时还没住进居民区。所以，除非你在家禽工厂工作，否则你与新来者的第一次真正接触可能是在车上。移民搬到阿尔伯特维尔后，肇事逃逸的案件增加了一倍多。我们见到的每个人似乎都有亲戚遭遇车祸或追尾的故事。再次请出Randy Amos，90年代阿尔伯特维尔的警察局长，以及他的继任者Benny Womack。
First of all, they didn't drive very well and not familiar with the laws over here. It put an extra load on our officers answering those calls.
首先，他们的驾驶技术不太好，也不熟悉这里的法律。这给我们的警员处理这些报案带来了额外负担。
They would run a stop sign, run a red light, DUI. They didn't have a driver's license, and they wouldn't have insurance.
他们会闯停车标志、闯红灯、酒驾。他们没有驾照，也没有保险。
And it was almost a common practice. If they had a crash, and their vehicle was not disabled, they would run.
这几乎是一种普遍的做法。如果他们发生了车祸，而车辆还能开，他们就会逃跑。
You know, you can understand that. Because they were in here-- in the US-- illegally. They didn't want to be in contact with law enforcement.
你知道，这可以理解。因为他们是非法居留在美国。他们不想与执法部门发生接触。
I talked to a bunch of the guys who arrived in the early waves of Mexican workers about this. They said, yeah, it's true. Most of them didn't know what they were doing on the road. Here's Claudio, who was in our first episode. He's speaking through an interpreter.
我采访了许多在早期来到这里的墨西哥工人。他们说，是的，这是真的。他们大多数人在路上开车时根本不知道自己在做什么。这是我们在第一集中采访过的Claudio。他通过翻译在说话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
He's like, I didn't know what that light was. I didn't know what that line meant.
他说：我不知道那个灯是什么意思。我不知道那条线意味着什么。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
No, they didn't know. They would just, like, drive around, like, without doing absolutely anything, totally like idiots.
不，他们不知道。他们就像白痴一样，根本不知道该干什么，只会在路上瞎开。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
You don't know what a stop was.
你不知道停车标志是什么。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
You don't know what speed limit was.
你不知道限速是什么。
Was that hard to figure out-- to learn all the rules?
理解并学习所有规则很难吗？
Si. Si.
是的。是的。
They came from really rural places, where some of the guys told me they got around on a donkey or a horse. They didn't drive cars.
他们来自非常偏远的乡村，一些人告诉我，他们以前靠驴或马代步。他们没开过车。
Of the dozens of people we talked to, one of the people with the most interesting and complicated perspectives on the conflict between the Latino newcomers and the white people in town is Jeannie Courington. She was a city council member, a small business owner-- the kind of a town booster who opened the town's recycling center and then worked there for free for years just to get it off the ground.
在我们交谈的几十个人中，对拉美裔新来者与当地白人冲突有着最有趣和复杂观点的人之一是Jeannie Courington。她曾是市议会议员、小企业主——她是那种支持小镇建设的推动者，她开设了小镇的回收中心，并为了使其运营，免费在那里工作了多年。
And she was one of the locals who stood between the two communities as a go-between, explaining one side to the other. And when things eventually got pretty heated between the two sides, she was one of the main voices in Albertville urging tolerance and understanding, though she started with some of the same feelings that other people had. Back in the '90's, when Mexican workers were first arriving in Albertville, she owned and ran the town's travel agency on Main Street, which, in those pre-internet days, people would come in to book flights home to Mexico. And she is very frank when she talks about what that was like for her.
她是站在两个群体之间的当地人之一，充当联络人，向一方解释另一方的情况。当双方最终发生激烈冲突时，她是阿尔伯特维尔呼吁宽容和理解的主要声音之一，尽管她最初也有和其他人一样的想法。在90年代，当墨西哥工人刚到阿尔伯特维尔时，她在主街开了一家旅行社。在没有互联网的年代，人们会来店里预订回墨西哥的机票。她在谈论当时的心情时非常坦诚。
I mean, I remember when they started coming in, because it was so-- it kind of made you nervous. They usually would come in multiples. They didn't come alone. I guess they were as afraid of us as we were afraid of them.
我的意思是，我记得他们刚开始来的时候，因为那真是……让人有点紧张。他们通常是一群一群地来。他们不单独行动。我想他们可能也像我们怕他们一样怕我们。
And there was just three women in the office. So it was kind of unnerving. Most of them kind of looked a little rough around the edges. [LAUGHS]
办公室里当时只有三个女人。所以那让人有点不安。他们大多数人看起来有点粗鲁。[笑]
It would be like if I was in a room with any minority. I'm just not used to-- that's just not my everyday, you know-- you just always are a little concerned in everything. Because it's the unknown. And the only thing you hear is the bad things. So it kind of unnerves you.
这就好比我和任何少数族裔待在一个房间里。我只是不习惯——这不是我的日常生活，你知道——你会对任何事情都保持一点警惕。因为那是未知的。你听到的唯一东西就是坏事。所以它会让你感到不安。
But she got used to being in a room with a minority. And that feeling changed for her. A lot of these early customers became regulars. And when the first Latino businessman moved onto Main Street with a little grocery store onto her same block, they ended up checking in with each other almost every day. This is him-- Jose Contreras.
但她习惯了与少数族裔待在一个房间里。那种感觉对她来说改变了。许多早期的客户成了常客。当第一位拉美裔商人带着一家杂货店搬到主街她的那条街区时，他们最终几乎每天都会互相问候。这就是他——Jose Contreras。
Well, when I just have a chance, I can just go over there and just say hi and blah, blah, blah, and, you know, make some jokes.
嗯，只要有机会，我就会走过去打个招呼，聊聊天之类的，你知道，开点玩笑。
Jose is always making jokes. It's his go-to move in lots of situations. He's from the Dominican Republic, then Florida and Georgia. He came to Albertville in the '90's, because he heard Mexicans were moving into town, and he saw an opportunity. Guys would line up in front of the store on payday, because he'd cash their checks.
Jose总是爱开玩笑。这是他在许多情况下的惯用手法。他来自多米尼加共和国，后来待过佛罗里达和佐治亚州。他在90年代来到阿尔伯特维尔，因为他听说墨西哥人正搬到这个镇上，他看到了机会。发薪日时，工人们会在他的店前排队，因为他会帮他们兑现支票。
And because he spoke English, and because he's this warm, friendly guy, he became the de facto community leader for Latino transplants. The person they'd go to for advice on how to navigate everything from housing to where to play soccer. Jose loves sports.
因为他会说英语，而且是一个热情友好的人，他成了拉美裔移民事实上的社区领袖。他们会向他寻求建议，从住房到去哪踢足球等方方面面。Jose热爱运动。
He jokes that he and Jeannie bonded because they're both outsiders.
他开玩笑说，他和Jeannie之所以关系好，是因为他们都是外地人。
Because she's not born in Albertville. She was born in Crossville.
因为她不是在阿尔伯特维尔出生的。她是在Crossville出生的。
Just, like, 10 minutes away.
离这只有10分钟路程。
Yeah. Well, no, it's about 25 minutes away.
嗯，不，大约25分钟路程。
(LAUGHING) OK, 25.
[大笑] 好的，25。
Yeah.
是的。
She said that you're definitely, like, the first Latino friend that she ever had.
她说你是她认识的第一个拉美裔朋友。
Yeah. [LAUGHS] Yes. I think so, yeah. Because she's a lady that-- she's in the-- I don't know what is the word that will come up to my mind. She's a high class lady. She's more open-minded, because she has traveled.
是的。[笑] 是的。我想是的。因为她是一位……我不知道脑子里冒出来的词是什么。她是一位高雅的女士。她思想更开明，因为她旅行过。
Was she the white person in town who you knew the best?
她是你在镇上认识的最好的白人吗？
Oh, yeah. She's the only one that I can trust. [LAUGHS]
哦，是的。她是唯一我能信任的人。[笑]
Jose explained to Jeannie a whole other way to look at people who are living here illegally, and what they go through, debunking all sorts of stuff. And so she went off reading and researching on her own and found herself suddenly this translator to the white people in town.
Jose向Jeannie解释了另一种看待非法移民的方式，以及他们的经历，驳斥了各种流言。因此，她开始自己阅读和研究，突然发现自己成为了镇上白人的翻译。
Somehow it would just always come up. It would come up about people being here illegal, and I would try to explain, well, our government makes it really hard for them to become legals. They have to go through so many steps.
不知怎么的，话题总是会转到这里。话题总是会涉及非法居留的人，我会试着解释说，政府让他们成为合法居民非常困难。他们必须经过太多的步骤。
And I'd try to explain, even though they may be illegal, somehow they've got a social security number, and they're paying taxes. I felt like I was always defending them. I just felt like-- I don't know. I guess I just had a sense in my gut that they're here to stay.
我会试着解释说，尽管他们可能是非法居留，但他们以某种方式拥有社会保障号码，并且在纳税。我觉得我总是在为他们辩护。我只是觉得……我不知道。我想我直觉感觉到他们会留在这里。
By 1996 or '97, with so many hundreds of people moving to town, housing's tight. The workers start moving from the trailer parks into rental houses in the neighborhoods around town, lots of them packed into single family homes. Some houses started moving their families up from Mexico.
到1996或1997年，随着数百人搬到镇上，住房变得紧张。工人们开始从拖车公园搬进镇上的出租屋，很多人挤在一栋单户住宅里。一些家庭开始把家人从墨西哥接过来。
Quick picture of the town-- Albertville is nice. There's a quaint little historic section in Main Street. The Tennessee River is nearby. It's pretty green. There's a four-lane highway with all the regular strip mall stuff and fast food. Most of the town is one-story houses with shutters, neatly mowed lawns, and little red flags for the high school band all over the place.
快速描绘一下这个镇子——阿尔伯特维尔很不错。主街上有一处古朴的历史街区。田纳西河就在附近。这里非常绿意盎然。有一条四车道的高速公路，沿路有各种常规的带状商场和快餐店。镇上的大部分建筑是带有百叶窗的平房，修剪整齐的草坪，到处都是高中乐队的小红旗。
And for the locals, anything in the residential areas that deviated from that look was not so welcome. And so after the traffic accidents, this becomes the next big deal in town. Jeannie gave us a driving tour and explained why this grated on people so much.
对于当地人来说，住宅区里任何偏离这种样貌的东西都不太受欢迎。所以继交通事故之后，这成了镇上的下一件大事。Jeannie带我们开车转了一圈，解释了为什么这让人们如此恼火。
If you look right here, just as an example, things like this would be what people would see and be very upset with.
如果你看这里，举个例子，人们看到这样的东西会非常心烦。
And just describe this yard.
你能描述一下这个院子吗？
Well, you have a car parked right in the front yard. You can see where they've destroyed the grass that's been on it because of all the traffic on it. You see garbage cans sitting right in the front door, trash scattered on the yard.
嗯，你看前院停着一辆车。你可以看到由于车子开进开出，草坪已经被破坏了。你看垃圾桶就放在前门口，院子里散落着垃圾。
Here, you see this next house. You've got one, two, three, four, five, six cars sitting in it.
这里，你看下一栋房子。院子里停了六辆车。
Years ago, there'd be lots of people living in one house. There'd be noise. Landlords wouldn't keep up the property. People moved in and out. They were there to make money, not settling into the neighborhood. And these were people from the countryside in Mexico, where a perfectly kept front lawn was not a thing.
几年前，一栋房子里会住很多人。会有噪音。房东不维护房产。人们搬进搬出。他们来这里是为了赚钱，而不是为了在社区定居。而这些人来自墨西哥农村，那里的人并不在意保持完美的草坪。
Residents were scared it would drive down property values. But for Albertville, overall, with thousands of people moving to town in a limited amount of housing, property values went up, faster than for the state as a whole. We drove by one house painted a bright lime green and another bright blue. There were houses in town with Christmas lights year round. Jeannie was like, that's just not what people here are used to.
居民们担心这会拉低房产价值。但总的来说，随着成千上万的人迁入，在住房有限的情况下，阿尔伯特维尔的房产价值反而上涨了，比该州整体上涨得更快。我们开车经过一栋漆成明亮酸橙绿色的房子和另一栋明亮的蓝色房子。镇上有些房子一年四季挂着圣诞彩灯。Jeannie说，这根本不是这里的人习惯看到的。
It's like, that's not our culture to do that.
就像，这样做不是我们的文化。
But when non-white people move into a white neighborhood nearly anywhere, you'll hear this-- like, messy yards, too many people in one house, too many cars. They're noisy. There's loud music-- like, that kind of stuff. And then often, that's code words for people just don't want non-white people moving in.
但是，当非白人搬入几乎任何地方的白人社区时，你都会听到这些——比如，脏乱的院子，一栋房子里住太多人，太多的汽车。他们很吵。音乐声很大——这类东西。而且通常，这些只是人们不想让非白人搬入的代号。
That's true. Yes, some of it is prejudice. You're going to look at the house and you think, I've got a wife and a five-year-old kid. That looks pretty trashy with all these cars there. That doesn't look safe for my family while I'm going to work.
那是真的。是的，其中一些确实是偏见。你看着那栋房子，你会想，我有一个妻子和一个五岁的孩子。那里停着这么多车看起来太脏了。在我去上班时，这对于我的家人来说看起来不安全。
That's the prejudice part.
那是偏见的部分。
It's really easy to show up in any small town anywhere and look at how people react to change and decide that it all belongs in this bucket of prejudice. But in Albertville, it was hard to parse out just how much was prejudice and how much was just people dealing with something new. That was real, also.
在任何小镇看到人们对变化的反应，并断定这全都是偏见，确实很容易。但在阿尔伯特维尔，很难理清其中有多少是偏见，有多少仅仅是人们在应对新事物。那也是真实的。
And we'd get into these conversations where people would ask us to take that seriously. Like, there really were more hit-and-runs. Some streets really did look different than they used to. One guy who worked at the local paper, whose family had lived in town for generations, put it this way. For a place which hadn't seen much change, it was just a lot to take in in a very short period of time.
我们经常陷入这种对话中，人们要求我们认真对待他们的感受。比如，确实有更多的肇事逃逸。有些街道看起来确实和过去不同。当地报纸的一位员工，其家人在这里生活了几代人，他是这样说的：对于一个没见过多少变化的地方，在这么短的时间内要消化这些确实很多。
People look different, and paint their houses differently, and speak a different language, and it just seemed to come out of nowhere. People did not know how to deal with it. Immigration economist George Borjas named a book after this great quote about immigration. The quote's about immigrants arriving in the country.
人们长相不同，粉刷房子的方式不同，说不同的语言，这一切似乎凭空出现。人们不知道该如何应对。移民经济学家George Borjas以关于移民的一句名言命名了一本书。这句话是关于移民来到这个国家。
Somebody once said, we wanted workers, but we got people instead-- meaning real people, who had their own ways of life. It might not match up with how people live in the new country. It's never easy. That's what happened in Albertville.
有人曾经说：我们需要的是劳动力，但我们得到的却是人——意思是真实的人，他们有自己的生活方式。这可能与新国家人们的生活方式不匹配。这从来都不容易。这就是阿尔伯特维尔发生的事情。
The next thing people noticed totally plays into all sorts of ugly stereotypes. People see Spanish names on the police blotter, which was printed in the local newspaper, the Sand Mountain Reporter. These were usually write-ups about driving without a license, DUIs, public intoxication-- small stuff. And then, years into all of this, people started seeing major crimes appear in the paper committed by Latino men around Albertville.
人们注意到的下一件事完全符合各种丑陋的刻板印象。人们在当地报纸《Sand Mountain Reporter》刊登的警务记录中看到了西班牙语名字。这些通常是关于无证驾驶、酒驾、公共场合酗酒的小文章。后来，几年之后，人们开始在报纸上看到拉美裔男子在阿尔伯特维尔附近犯下重大罪行。
A man was shot and dismembered just outside of town. Five pounds of meth were seized in a drug raid. Five brothels were busted in the trailer parks around town. Chief of Police Benny Womack says brothels were something the town had never seen before.
镇外发生了一起枪杀分尸案。缉毒行动中查获了五磅冰毒。镇上的拖车公园里查封了五个妓院。警察局长Benny Womack说，妓院是镇上以前从未见过的事物。
The Hispanic community was getting all the attention about crime and that sort of thing. It becomes a big issue for the citizens.
拉美裔社区在犯罪等方面得到了所有关注。这成了市民的一个大问题。
Immigrant crime, of course, is one of those big topics where liberals and conservatives square off with their arguments that are, at this point, very familiar to many of us. But liberals point out that most studies on immigrant crime show that people who immigrate to this country are less likely to commit crimes than native born Americans. America Firsters say that even one crime committed by somebody who's not in the country illegally is a crime too many, and we shouldn't stand for it. That's the president's view, and he set up a federal office that documents these crimes.
移民犯罪，当然是自由派和保守派争论的重大议题之一，到目前为止，这些论点我们许多人都非常熟悉。但自由派指出，大多数关于移民犯罪的研究表明，移民到这个国家的人比美国本土出生的人犯罪的可能性更小。美国优先主义者则说，即便一个非法入境的人犯下一项罪行，也是太多的罪行，我们不应该容忍。那是总统的观点，他建立了一个联邦办公室来记录这些罪行。
So putting the rhetoric aside, how exactly did this play out in this one small town in Alabama? Well, during the period when the immigrants arrived-- 1990 to 2010-- there was an explosion of all kinds of crime in town. The numbers are kind of stunning. Arrests for drug possession quintupled. Property crime rates more than tripled. That's burglary, theft, and car theft. Violent crimes almost quadrupled, though in the last few years, they've fallen back to where they started.
所以撇开口水战不谈，在这一个阿拉巴马州的小镇上，情况究竟是如何演变的呢？嗯，在移民到来的时期——1990年到2010年——镇上的各类犯罪确实出现了爆发式增长。数字相当惊人。毒品持有逮捕次数增加了五倍。财产犯罪率增加了两倍多。也就是入室盗窃、偷窃和汽车盗窃。暴力犯罪几乎增加了四倍，尽管在过去几年里，它们已经回落到了起始水平。
But I talked to John Siggers, who's the commander of the drug enforcement unit for the county Albertville is in-- Marshall County-- and was an Albertville police officer from 1997 to 2007, right in the middle of the period that we're talking about. And I asked him about all that extra crime.
但我采访了John Siggers，他是阿尔伯特维尔所在县——马歇尔县——缉毒部门的指挥官，并且在1997年到2007年期间担任阿尔伯特维尔警察，正好处于我们讨论的时期。我问了他关于所有额外犯罪的问题。
Are most of the drug arrests Latinos?
大多数毒品逮捕是拉美裔吗？
No. No. Absolutely not. Most of the meth possession cases are-- I would say-- 90-something percent Caucasian.
不。不。绝对不是。大多数冰毒持有案件……我会说是90%以上是白人。
And what about the property crime cases in town?
那么镇上的财产犯罪案件呢？
That would be Caucasian.
那也是白人。
He explained these kinds of property crime rates are just a side effect of drug use and drug crime. It's people stealing to feed their habits.
他解释说，这类财产犯罪率只是毒品使用和毒品犯罪的副作用。人们为了满足毒瘾而偷窃。
You know, that happens, not just in Albertville, not just in Marshall County or Alabama, but all over the country.
你知道，这不仅仅发生在阿尔伯特维尔，不仅仅是在马歇尔县或阿拉巴马州，而是遍及全国。
The way police describe it there was an epidemic of meth use around Albertville that started around the time the immigrants arrived. It was all over the country back then and unrelated to their arrival. Around Albertville, there was mostly home-cooked meth. But then state law made it difficult to get the ingredients for home-cooked meth, and the Mexican drug cartel stepped in using Albertville as a base to supply a swath of northern Alabama.
警方描述说，阿尔伯特维尔周围曾出现过冰毒泛滥，这大约在移民到来时开始。当时全国各地都有这种情况，与他们的到来无关。在阿尔伯特维尔周围，大多是家庭作坊式冰毒。但后来州法律限制了自制冰毒成分的获取，墨西哥贩毒集团便介入，利用阿尔伯特维尔作为基地，向阿拉巴马州北部供应毒品。
Sigger says today that every meth arrest they make they can trace back to Mexican distributors. But Sigger says that if there were no Latino population in Albertville, there very well might be just as much drug and property crime in town, because the meth would just come in through Atlanta.
Siggers说，今天他们逮捕的每一起冰毒案件，最终都能追溯到墨西哥分销商。但Siggers说，如果阿尔伯特维尔没有拉美裔人口，镇上的毒品和财产犯罪很可能依然一样多，因为冰毒依然会通过亚特兰大运进来。
So whether the Hispanic population was here or not, Atlanta is still the hub. And we're located three hours from Atlanta. The drugs would still come in here.
所以不管拉美裔人口是否在这里，亚特兰大依然是中心。我们离亚特兰大只有三个小时的路程。毒品依然会运到这里。
So Albertville is in this strange situation where most of the immigrant residents are not involved in drug trafficking or organized crime. The police say they actually tip them off about crimes. And if the immigrants had never been to town, the amount of drug trafficking and crime really might not have been very different in Albertville. But that is not the conclusion people are drawing from what they read in the newspaper.
所以阿尔伯特维尔处于这种奇怪的境地：大多数移民居民并不参与毒品走私或有组织犯罪。警方说他们实际上会向警方举报犯罪。如果移民从未到过镇上，毒品走私和犯罪的总量在阿尔伯特维尔可能真的不会有太大差别。但这并不是人们从报纸上阅读后得出的结论。
For the first decade and a half that Latino families were moving to Albertville, probably the best place to track how longtime residents were feeling about the changes was in the local paper, the Sand Mountain Reporter. They had letters to the editor in a column called "Speak Out," where any irate resident could call an answering machine and leave an anonymous message that would then get printed in the paper.
在拉美裔家庭搬到阿尔伯特维尔的前十五年里，要了解长期居民对变化的感受，最好的地方可能是当地报纸《Sand Mountain Reporter》。他们有一个名为“大声说出来”（Speak Out）的专栏，任何愤怒的居民都可以拨打答录机留下匿名留言，然后刊登在报纸上。
People complained pretty much any time the city spent money on Latino residents. And then an equal number of their neighbors would call the complainers "bigots" and tell them to go read their bibles, which didn't stop anyone.
每当城市在拉美裔居民身上花钱时，人们几乎都会抱怨。然后同样多的邻居会称这些抱怨者为“顽固分子”，并叫他们回去读圣经，但这并没有阻止任何人。
It was like every week, every week. People were just like, get all these illegals out of here, taking the welfare and using it, taking our jobs, doing crime-- like every week, every week, every week.
这就像每周，每周。人们只是说，把这些非法移民都弄走，领着福利，用着钱，抢我们的工作，犯罪——就像每周，每周，每周这样。
This is Ricky Ibarra, one of the first Latino graduates of Albertville High School, part of the generation of kids who grew up speaking English, and whose parents moved to town to work in the poultry plants. He says the older Latino people, they don't read the newspaper.
这是Ricky Ibarra，阿尔伯特维尔高中第一批毕业的拉美裔学生之一，他是成长中说英语的一代，父母搬到镇上是为了在家禽工厂工作。他说，年纪较大的拉美裔人是不看报纸的。
But, like, the college students, high school students, we're more to what's going on, you know? So you would want to read it just to see what the atmosphere was.
但是，像大学生、高中生，我们更关注发生了什么，你知道吗？所以你会想读它，只是为了看看氛围如何。
And it was pretty bad it sounds like.
听起来情况相当糟糕。
But it was bad because you read it-- or at least, to me-- I would read it and-- I mean, I used to work in companies where we were just surrounded. Sometimes I was the only Mexican there. So it used to have me feeling like, I wonder if they're thinking the same thing, which-- I mean, that was bad, because some of the people I used to work with they were pretty good with me.
但它很糟糕是因为你读了它——至少对我来说——我会读它，而且……我的意思是，我曾经在公司工作，我们被包围着。有时我是那里唯一的墨西哥人。所以这让我感觉，我想知道他们是否也在想同样的事情，而——我的意思是，那很糟糕，因为和我一起工作的一些人对我相当不错。
But it would just mess up the whole day. Because you would see that early in the morning. And then it'd just have you thinking thoughts.
但它会毁掉一整天。因为你一大早就看到了那些。然后它会让你开始胡思乱想。
Which brings us to act two, The March. In 2006, President Bush tries to get Congress to create a path to citizenship for undocumented immigrants. There's a wave of marches around the country in support of that.
这把我们带到了第二幕，游行。2006年，布什总统试图让国会为无证移民创造一条入籍途径。全国各地出现了支持这一举措的游行浪潮。
Good evening. The issue of immigration stirs intense emotions. And in recent weeks, Americans have seen those emotions on display. On the streets of major cities, crowds have rallied in support of those in our country illegally.
晚上好。移民问题激起了强烈的情绪。最近几周，美国人亲眼目睹了这些情绪的展现。在大城市的街道上，人群集会支持那些非法居留我们国家的人。
Ricky and a bunch of other Latino residents who had been living in town for a while and spoke English started talking about whether they should organize a march in Albertville for immigrants. They tried to enlist Jose Contreras, the guy with the grocery store on Main Street, who they were buddies with. Here's Jose.
Ricky和一群已经在镇上住了有一阵子、会说英语的拉美裔居民开始讨论他们是否应该在阿尔伯特维尔组织一场移民游行。他们试图拉拢在主街开杂货店的Jose Contreras，他们是朋友。这是Jose。
I'd say, are you crazy? You're going to be all in jail. [LAUGHS] And he said, why? Why? I said, because you have to ask for permission. Are you sure? I said, let me find out. I can find out. And I called Jeannie.
我说，你们疯了吗？你们都会被关进监狱的。[笑] 他说，为什么？为什么？我说，因为你必须请求许可。你确定吗？我说，让我查一下。我可以查一下。然后我打了电话给Jeannie。
Jeannie, of course, his friend on the city council who owned the travel agency. At this point, Albertville is around 20% Latino. The population has been growing for 15 years. But there's been no official outreach from the city. There's no Latino resident on the city council. So this was the back-channel way things would get done.
Jeannie，当然，是他在市议会的朋友，开着一家旅行社。此时，阿尔伯特维尔的拉美裔人口占比约为20%。人口增长了15年。但城市方面没有任何官方的外联工作。市议会里也没有拉美裔议员。所以这是一种非官方的解决方式。
Jose would talk to Jeannie about things going on in the community. Jeannie would take it to the people running the city.
Jose会和Jeannie谈论社区里发生的事情。Jeannie会把它带给管理城市的人。
And so he brought it to my attention. And then I went to the mayor and the city council president at that time. And they kind of just laughed. And they didn't think it was-- nobody's going to show up. So needless to say, everybody was a little bit shocked when there was about 5,000 people.
所以他把这件事引起了我的注意。然后我找到了当时的市长和市议会主席。他们只是笑了笑。他们没觉得会……没人会参加。所以不用说，当有大约5000人出现时，每个人都感到有些震惊。
5,000 marchers poured through the streets of Albertville, blocking off the lane of traffic. White people were shocked. Latino people were shocked. The organizers were shocked.
5000名游行者涌上阿尔伯特维尔的街道，堵塞了行车道。白人感到震惊。拉美裔人感到震惊。组织者感到震惊。
Oh, yeah. We were laughing. I was laughing. We were like, I don't know what we did.
哦，是的。我们在笑。我在笑。我们就像是，我不知道我们做了什么。
Jeannie shared a snapshot she took of the crowd-- a long, calm procession.
Jeannie分享了她拍的一张人群快照——一支漫长、平静的队伍。
All the people-- yes, they all wore white shirts. But they all-- if you notice that they all were carrying an American flag and talking about being-- I don't have my glasses on. So I can't read their sign there. So-- but--
所有这些人——是的，他们都穿着白衬衫。但他们都……如果你注意到，他们都带着美国国旗，谈论着……我没戴眼镜，所以我读不出他们标语上的字。所以……但是……
We love the USA.
我们爱美国。
Yes.
是的。
The organizers told people not to bring Mexican flags. People picked up litter along the route. Jose and his friend Luis reimbursed the police department for their officers' overtime during the march. Again, here's Ricky.
组织者告诉人们不要带墨西哥国旗。人们捡起了沿途的垃圾。Jose和他的朋友Luis补偿了警察局在游行期间警员的加班费。再次请出Ricky。
It was actually the biggest crowd in Alabama, even bigger than Birmingham and Hunstville.
这实际上是阿拉巴马州规模最大的人群，甚至比伯明翰和亨茨维尔还要大。
I mean, do you think this march-- do you think it freaked out some people in town to see in such--
我的意思是，你认为这场游行——你认为这让镇上的一些人感到惊恐了吗……
Oh, I think it did. I mean, I think that's what it did, really. Because they were more stunned.
哦，我想是的。我的意思是，我想那就是它所带来的，真的。因为他们更惊呆了。
I think it did freak the people out of the community.
我想这确实让社区里的人感到恐慌。
Again, Jeannie.
再次请出Jeannie。
It was a shock. I mean, it was like, holy cow, you know? I've never seen this many people-- you know, they'd see them around town but never in that massive a number. It was just kind of hard for our town to kind of absorb.
那是一个冲击。我的意思是，这就像，天哪，你知道吗？我从来没见过这么多人——你知道，他们会在镇上看到他们，但从来没见过如此庞大的数量。这对于我们的小镇来说有点难以消化。
So it was like a wake-up call.
所以这就像一个警钟。
Yeah, kind of. And they were afraid they were going to take over their town.
是的，某种程度上。而且他们害怕他们会接管他们的小镇。
Why did you take these pictures?
你为什么要拍这些照片？
Well, I guess I felt like, at that time, it was a moment of history.
嗯，我想在那一刻，我感到这是一个历史瞬间。
And it is a historical moment. What does it represent?
它确实是一个历史瞬间。它代表什么？
Change.
变化。
Coming up-- why some of the people in the march came to regret it. That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来——为什么游行中的一些人开始后悔。一分钟后，当我们的节目在芝加哥公共广播电台继续时，我们将揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. It's our second program about Albertville, Alabama, the town that went from nearly all white to more than 1/4 Latino in two decades. My co-host today is Miki Meek. We've arrived at act three of our program. Act three-- Backlash.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。这是我们关于阿拉巴马州阿尔伯特维尔的第二个节目，这个小镇在二十年内从几乎全是白人变成了超过1/4是拉美裔。我今天的共同主持人是Miki Meek。我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕——反弹。
So after the march, now that the locals had realized just how many Latino families had moved into town, a long period of backlash kicks off. At first, it's modest. The city council passes a few new ordinances and starts enforcing a few old ones, hoping to clean up the way things look around town. Oh, and by the way, if you want to hold a march, you now needed to apply 10 days in advance.
所以游行之后，现在当地人已经意识到有多少拉美裔家庭搬进了镇上，一段长期的反弹开始了。起初，反弹是很温和的。市议会通过了一些新条例，并开始执行一些旧条例，希望清理镇上的面貌。哦，顺便说一句，如果你想举行游行，你现在需要提前10天申请。
They also tried to get the federal government to deport people. The police partner up with ICE-- Immigration and Customs Enforcement-- so that anytime they have someone in jail they suspect is undocumented, they call ICE. In the first year, 300 people are turned over into ICE custody. And the city asks the feds to give Albertville police officers the power to do immigration arrests. Police Chief Benny Womack said most people in town didn't understand that his officers couldn't enforce federal immigration law.
他们还试图让联邦政府驱逐人们。警方与ICE（美国移民和海关执法局）建立了伙伴关系，以便他们在监狱里怀疑某人是无证移民时，就会打电话给ICE。第一年，有300人被移交给ICE拘留。城市请求联邦政府给予阿尔伯特维尔警员进行移民逮捕的权力。警察局长Benny Womack说，镇上大多数人不知道为什么他的警员不能处理那个问题。
You see, the citizens-- and probably still don't-- know why a police officer, a local police officer, can't do something about that problem. That's where I was getting flack. Why don't you do something? You're a cop. And sometimes even if you explain it to them, they don't understand.
你看，市民们——可能到现在也不知道——为什么一名警员，一名当地警员，不能对那个问题采取行动。那就是我挨骂的地方。你为什么不采取行动？你是警察。有时即使你向他们解释了，他们也不理解。
If Benny wanted his cops to make immigration arrests, they had to get special authorization and training under a federal program called 287(g). The city applied for it. Their congressmen and their senator, Jeff Sessions, went to bat for them. A handful of officers did some training with ICE, and Benny kept requesting 287(g) authorization and a detention facility to hold immigration violators.
如果Benny想让他的警察进行移民逮捕，他们必须获得名为287(g)的联邦项目的特别授权和培训。城市申请了这个项目。他们的国会议员和他们的参议员杰夫·塞申斯为他们撑腰。少数警员接受了一些ICE的培训，Benny不断请求287(g)授权和一个用来关押移民违法者的拘留设施。
But it all fell apart. Federal priorities changed, and they never ended up getting the authorization they wanted.
但这一切都泡汤了。联邦优先事项发生了改变，他们最终没能得到他们想要的授权。
While all of this was going on in town, this interesting thing happened. The anti-immigration forces on the national scene scored a huge victory against the president of the United States, President Bush, and a bipartisan group of senators. They killed off Bush's proposed path to legal status in 2007. And then, with the wind at their backs, they headed out into a period of energized experimentation in Arizona, Georgia, and in Alabama.
当所有这一切在镇上进行时，发生了一件有趣的事。全国范围内的反移民势力在总统布什和一群两党参议员身上取得了一场巨大的胜利。他们在2007年扼杀了布什提出的合法化途径。然后，在势头的推动下，他们进入了一个充满活力的实验时期，在亚利桑那州、佐治亚州和阿拉巴马州。
They started raising the flag on the issue around the state. A conservative group called The Eagle Forum held public meetings in Mobile, Montgomery, Huntsville, Tuscaloosa, Birmingham. State legislators sounded the alarm about how undocumented immigrants were a drain on taxpayers and how they drove down wages and stole jobs. Joe Hubbard was a state representative for Montgomery, a Democrat, who noticed how his Republican colleagues seemed to be strategizing from a new playbook. He says that before this--
他们开始在全州范围内就这个问题竖起旗帜。一个名为“鹰派论坛”（The Eagle Forum）的保守派组织在莫比尔、蒙哥马利、亨茨维尔、塔斯卡卢萨、伯明翰召开了公开会议。州立法者敲响警钟，称无证移民是纳税人的负担，称他们压低工资并偷走工作。Joe Hubbard是蒙哥马利的一名州众议员，一位民主党人，他注意到他的共和党同事似乎在从一套新的剧本中制定策略。他说，在此之前——
Your state legislator was as local a politician as you got. He was the guy that you talked to about schools. He was the guy that you talked to about funding for that road project you need. I think that from 2004 to 2006-- and ultimately, in 2010-- you saw efforts by the Alabama Republican Party to nationalize local elections, and to talk about what's going on in DC, the Congressional Democrats, Nancy Pelosi, on and on. I think there was polling that showed immigration, which, heretofore, has been a national issue, could make for good state political fodder.
你的州立法者是你所能接触到的最基层的政客。他就是你谈论学校的人。他就是你谈论你需要的那条道路项目资金的人。我认为从2004年到2006年——最终，在2010年——你看到了阿拉巴马州共和党为将地方选举国家化所做的努力，谈论在华盛顿特区发生的事情，国会民主党人，南希·佩洛西，等等。我认为有民调显示，移民问题，到目前为止一直是个国家性议题，可以成为很好的州政治食粮。
The person leading the charge in Alabama was a Republican state senator, Scott Beason. As he stumped the state calling for action, he got accused of trying to rile up voters over something that was a non-problem in Alabama. Alabama's not Arizona or Texas. They just didn't have that many immigrants, documented or undocumented. It was just 3% of the population. Only a handful of states had fewer. But Beason had an answer at the ready.
在阿拉巴马州领导这一行动的人是共和党州参议员Scott Beason。当他走遍全州呼吁采取行动时，他被指责试图煽动选民关注一个在阿拉巴马州不存在的问题。阿拉巴马州不是亚利桑那州或德克萨斯州。他们根本没有那么多移民，无论合法还是非法。这只是人口的3%。只有极少数州比这更少。但Beason准备好了答案。
And a lot of people said, let's don't deal with this issue, because we don't have a big population. So why would you deal with it? But what I looked out and saw was the states that did not deal with it decades ago eventually became paralyzed, because the population had grown so big businesses were addicted to the labor. So we were trying to nip it in the bud.
很多人说，让我们不要处理这个问题，因为我们没有庞大的人口。所以你为什么要处理它呢？但我看到的是，那些几十年前没有处理这个问题的州最终变得瘫痪，因为人口增长得如此之大，以至于企业对这种劳动力产生了依赖。所以我们正试图将其扼杀在萌芽状态。
And when you were going around, talking about this around the state, did you feel like it was popular? Did you feel like people were on your side?
当你在全州范围内谈论这个问题时，你觉得它受欢迎吗？你觉得人们站在你这边吗？
Oh, absolutely. Absolutely.
哦，绝对。绝对。
What was the polling like?
民调结果如何？
It was overwhelming.
那是压倒性的。
Beason's an environmental consultant turned Tea Party politician-- a chatty guy. And his first big win was convincing the legislature to create a special commission, which he co-chaired-- the Alabama Patriotic Immigration Commission-- to hold hearings around the state on the issue. Albertville inserts itself into this discussion more than any other city in the state of Alabama.
Beason是一个环境顾问出身的茶党政客——一个健谈的人。他的第一次重大胜利是说服议会建立一个特别委员会，他担任共同主席——阿拉巴马爱国移民委员会——在全州范围内就该问题举行听证会。阿尔伯特维尔在这一讨论中插入得比阿拉巴马州任何其他城市都要多。
People were saying Albertville is a place you need to check out. It just kind of bubbled to the top.
人们都在说阿尔伯特维尔是你需要去看看的地方。它就像是自动冒到了最前面。
Scott Beason says-- and there's no doubt it's true-- that the person who pushed Albertville to the top was a longtime Albertville resident named Teresa Ferguson.
Scott Beason说——毫无疑问这是真的——那个把阿尔伯特维尔推到最前面的人是一位长期的阿尔伯特维尔居民，名叫Teresa Ferguson。
I know Teresa well. Well, a lot of Republicans in the state know Teresa. And a lot of that is from her efforts of saying, hey, come look and see what is going on here.
我非常了解Teresa。嗯，州里很多共和党人都认识Teresa。这很大程度上源于她努力说：嘿，来看看这里发生了什么。
How would you describe Teresa Ferguson?
你会怎么描述Teresa Ferguson？
I think she's a great lady. I would say one of her gifts is the ability to reach out to elected officials. And I think she really cares about her community. And she's one of the nicest people I've ever met.
我认为她是一位伟大的女士。我会说她的天赋之一是接触民选官员的能力。而且我认为她真心关心她的社区。她是我见过的最好的人之一。
Now, there's a whole a cake. I mean, there's plenty more.
现在，这儿有一整块蛋糕。我的意思是，还有很多。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Of the dozens of interviews that we did in people's homes in Alabama, this was the only one that started with an Italian cream layer cake, served by our interviewee, Teresa Ferguson. Teresa is in her 60s, runs a pearl jewelry business from her house-- one of her sons, a big political strategist. And Teresa is so connected in the world of Alabama politics that during our interview, at a personal request, the state's current attorney general dropped by.
在我们对阿拉巴马州居民进行的几十次采访中，这是唯一一次以意大利奶油蛋糕开始的采访，由我们的受访者Teresa Ferguson提供。Teresa六十多岁，在家经营一家珍珠首饰生意——她的一个儿子是位重要的政治策略师。Teresa在阿拉巴马州政治圈内的人脉非常广，以至于在我们采访期间，应个人请求，该州现任司法部长顺道拜访了。
Are you sure you don't want a piece of cake?
你确定不要一块蛋糕吗？
I'm great. Thank you. At a community event--
不用了，谢谢。在一次社区活动中——
Teresa was on the stage with Donald Trump this year when he came to the state to endorse Luther Strange for Senate. And she's known Jeff Sessions for years. She first got to know him to get help with a family situation. Her daughter-in-law is Chinese, and was in China about to have a baby, having a hard time getting a visa. And the process was just taking too long. And she was introduced to Sessions when he was visiting a local hospital.
今年特朗普来到该州支持Luther Strange竞选参议员时，Teresa与他同台。她认识杰夫·塞申斯很多年了。她最初通过寻求家庭情况的帮助而认识他。她的儿媳是中国人，当时在中国正准备生孩子，签证申请遇到了困难。过程太耗时了。他们在塞申斯访问当地医院时被介绍给了他。
And I told him-- I said-- as a joke-- I said, I probably should just fly her to Mexico and bring her in the back of a pickup truck. That would be a lot easier. That's the way everybody else does it. You know?
我告诉他——我半开玩笑地说——我可能应该直接飞往墨西哥，然后用皮卡车后座把她运进来。那会容易得多。其他人都是这么做的。你知道吧？
And what did he say?
他说了什么？
And he just kind of laughed and had this funny look on his face, I think.
我想他只是笑了笑，脸上露出那种好笑的表情。
She ran into him at other events. She started telling him about all the problems in Albertville she felt were caused by undocumented immigrants.
她在其他活动中也遇到了他。她开始告诉他所有她觉得是无证移民在阿尔伯特维尔造成的问题。
And he was just so nice to listen. I mean, he's just such a nice man, anyway-- just a precious person. And he listened-- you know, because you have a couple of minutes to bend their ear a little. And then after that, I guess after you talk to him a couple of times, there's my friend. [LAUGHS]
他真的非常乐意倾听。我的意思是，他本来就是个非常好的人——一个珍贵的人。他听了——你知道，因为你有几分钟的时间让他们听听你的意见。在那之后，我想在你和他谈过几次之后，这就是我的朋友了。[笑]
Teresa's beef with the undocumented immigrants in town was a mix of things, including the belief that they were costing the town money it just couldn't afford.
Teresa对镇上无证移民的不满是多种原因的混合，包括他们认为这些移民正在耗费镇上无法承担的资金。
You get labeled a racist if you just want to even discuss. It's that you're here, and it's against the law, and we're paying for you to be here. You're not paying your taxes. You're going to school free.
如果你仅仅是想讨论一下，你就会被贴上种族主义者的标签。事实是你们在这里，这是违法的，而我们正在为你们在这里付费。你们没在纳税。你们在免费上学。
We get into that later in the show. We asked an economist to run the numbers on that for us. Teresa talks about teacher friends of theirs-- her husband worked for the public schools before he retired-- who have to pick and choose what they buy at the grocery store. And then they see Latino families in the cashier line with food stamps-- and I just want to say, I know they're not food stamps anymore, but that's what everybody in town calls them. Kids who are born here can get them even if their parents are undocumented.
我们稍后会在节目中谈到这一点。我们请了一位经济学家为我们核算这些数字。Teresa谈到了他们认识的教师朋友——她丈夫退休前曾在公立学校工作——他们必须在杂货店里精打细算买什么东西。然后他们看到拉美裔家庭在结账排队时使用食品券——我想说，我知道现在那不再叫食品券了，但镇上每个人都这么叫。在这里出生的孩子即使父母是无证移民也能领到。
The last time I went through the line, just as an example, the family did not speak English. One child-- probably about 10-- they had several children-- spoke English-- very polite, very nice. They finished with their groceries. Cashier said, your groceries were, like, $93-- something like that. That will be $2.69. When you see that time and time and time again--
上次我去排队时，举个例子，那个家庭不说英语。一个孩子——大约10岁——他们有好几个孩子——说英语——非常有礼貌，非常友善。他们结账时买的杂货大概是93美元……就那样。结果只需要付2.69美元。当你一次又一次看到这种情况时……
When you see something like that-- people in the grocery store-- like, it's possible those kids are American citizens.
当你看到那样的事——在杂货店里——比如，那些孩子可能是美国公民。
Well, they are. Because they have the WIC card. The parents, probably, are not.
嗯，他们是。因为他们有WIC卡。父母，可能不是。
So do you feel like it's unfair if the kids are citizens?
所以如果孩子是公民，你觉得不公平吗？
Nothing's ever fair. That's not the deal. But you know, we can't take care of everybody. So you have to look to take care of the people in your own country first.
没有什么事是绝对公平的。那不是重点。但你知道，我们不能照顾每一个人。所以你必须先照顾好你自己的国家的人。
In 2008, the group that was organizing meetings about immigration around the state-- The Eagle Forum-- asked Teresa to organize one in Albertville. And she did.
2008年，那个在全州组织有关移民会议的组织——“鹰派论坛”——要求Teresa在阿尔伯特维尔组织一场。她做了。
The immigration debate took center stage at a town hall meeting in Marshall County tonight. WAFF 48's Trang Do joins us live in Albertville. Trang, the scene got pretty heated.
移民辩论今晚在马歇尔县的市政厅会议上成为焦点。WAFF 48台的Trang Do在阿尔伯特维尔现场为我们直播。Trang，现场气氛变得相当激烈。
Emotions ran high at the two-hour meeting tonight. And many were eager to voice their opinions. The meeting attracted more than 200 people on both sides of the immigration debate.
今晚两个小时的会议情绪高涨。许多人急于表达他们的意见。会议吸引了超过200名在移民辩论双方的人员。
I just remember standing in the door, greeting everybody as they would come in. Thank you for coming! It was popping at the seams that night-- mostly people I didn't know!
我只记得站在门口，迎接每一个进来的人。谢谢你们的到来！那天晚上门口都挤爆了——大多是我不认识的人！
At the meeting, people weren't complaining like always about the local stuff-- about messy yards and uninsured drivers. Everybody agreed that they were part of a bigger story. This wasn't just Albertville's problem. It was Alabama's and the country's. And for the first time, they got a glimpse that they could rise up and do something about it.
在会议上，人们不再像往常一样抱怨当地的琐事——关于杂乱的院子和没保险的司机。大家都同意他们是更大故事的一部分。这不仅仅是阿尔伯特维尔的问题。这是阿拉巴马州和全国的问题。而且这是第一次，他们瞥见自己可以站起来并为此做点什么。
The 90-minute presentation explained how they could fight the problem at the local, state, and national levels, and how to pressure their representatives. Speakers urged them to support a new anti-immigration bill that was going to be coming up in the state capital.
90分钟的演示解释了他们如何在地方、州和国家层面上对抗这个问题，以及如何向他们的代表施压。发言者敦促他们支持一项即将出现在州首府的新反移民法案。
And in the wake of that meeting, Teresa and a couple people start this group, Concerned Citizens, where they try to figure out what can be done next. It's not a big group-- maybe 10 to 12 regulars. But two of them ended up running for office. And they defined the city's new political climate.
在那次会议之后，Teresa和几个人成立了一个小组，叫“关注市民”（Concerned Citizens），试图找出下一步能做什么。这不是一个大团体——也许10到12个常客。但其中两个人最终竞选了公职。他们定义了城市新的政治气候。
By the time the next election came around in Albertville, in the summer of 2008, immigration was the main thing everyone was talking about-- fueled by Concerned Citizens and a new statewide fervor over the issue. Their senator, Jeff Sessions, came to City Hall and talked to an overflow audience of mostly older white folks who fumed about the expense to taxpayers and 287(g), that program the police wanted that would let them enforce immigration laws. Sessions promised to follow up and get their officers trained.
到了2008年夏天，阿尔伯特维尔下一次选举到来时，移民是每个人都在谈论的主要议题——受到“关注市民”组织和全州范围内对该问题的新热情的推动。他们的参议员杰夫·塞申斯来到市政厅，面对一群挤满的听众，大多是担心纳税人开支和警察想要的那个287(g)项目（即允许他们执行移民法的程序）的老年白人。塞申斯承诺会跟进并培训他们的警员。
In the city council race that year, there was a lot of talk about how the city was at a critical juncture. Jeannie Courington, the travel agent who found herself always explaining the Latino population to their white neighbors, was an incumbent on the city council back then. And she ran for mayor to try to redirect the conversation away from confrontation. At the candidate forum, she says, people demanded action.
在那一年的市议会竞选中，有很多谈论说城市正处于一个关键时刻。Jeannie Courington，那位总是发现自己要向白人邻居解释拉美裔人口的旅行社老板，当时是市议会的现任议员。她竞选市长，试图将对话从对抗中重新引导。在候选人论坛上，她说，人们要求采取行动。
You know, I think everybody thought that you could do something about it-- that you could, you know, control it. And you know, we couldn't control that. We can't build a wall around Albertville. But those were some of the things. I mean, they were just naive enough to think that-- I mean, that would be a direct question. If you're elected mayor, what are you going to do about all these Hispanics or illegals in town?
你知道，我认为每个人都以为你可以做点什么——你可以，你知道，控制它。你知道，我们无法控制那个。我们不能在阿尔伯特维尔周围筑起一堵墙。但那些就是其中的一些内容。我的意思是，他们天真地以为……我的意思是，那会是一个直接的问题。如果你当选市长，你打算如何处理镇上所有这些拉美裔或非法移民？
What are you going to do, meaning to get rid of them.
你打算如何处理，意思是摆脱他们。
Yeah. Uh-huh. Exactly.
是的。嗯哼。正是如此。
And what would you say?
你会怎么说？
Well, they're here in our community, and I believe that they're here to stay. We need to befriend them. It's not going to be the all-white, sweet little community we used to be.
嗯，他们在这里，在我们的社区，我相信他们会留下来。我们需要与他们友好相处。它不会再是以前那个全白人的、甜蜜的小社区了。
And do you think that hurt you with voters?
你认为这伤害了你的选票吗？
I think so.
我想是的。
Her friend Jose told her that her strategy was all wrong if she wanted to win. Here's how she needed to talk about immigrants.
她的朋友Jose告诉她，如果她想赢，她的策略全错了。这是她需要如何谈论移民的方法。
Kick them out. Tell them that you're going to kick them out each by each.
把他们踢出去。告诉他们你要一个接一个地把他们踢出去。
Wait, you told Jeannie to just lie? Just say you're going to kick out all the immigrants?
等等，你告诉Jeannie直接撒谎？直接说你要踢走所有移民？
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I said, go ahead and say a lie, because-- and she'd never say it. She never said it. She never said it.
是的。是的。是的。我说，去说个谎吧，因为……而她从没说过。她从没说过。她从没说过。
And that's why she lost.
这就是她落选的原因。
Jose wasn't right about what the voters wanted. Most people in town turned out not to be as worked up as that. They did not pick a hard-liner. They chose a pretty moderate mayor, Randy Amos. He's the police chief you heard at the top of the show explaining that killing a goat did not violate city law. His views on immigration weren't that different from Jeannie's. He got more than twice the votes of any other candidate.
Jose对于选民想要什么并不正确。事实证明镇上大多数人并没有那么激动。他们没有选择强硬派。他们选择了一位相当温和的市长，Randy Amos。他就是你在节目开头听到的那位解释杀山羊不违反市政法的警察局长。他对移民的看法与Jeannie并无不同。他的得票数超过了其他任何候选人的两倍。
But in a stunning and unexpected turn of events, because of a fluke, the town went in a direction they did not choose. Right after the vote, the city found out that someone in Randy's campaign had missed the deadline to file some campaign forms. They couldn't certify him as the winner of the mayor's race.
但由于一次巧合，在令人震惊和意想不到的转折中，城镇向着他们没有选择的方向发展了。投票结束后，城市发现Randy竞选团队中有人错过了提交竞选表格的截止日期。他们不能证明他是市长的获胜者。
Instead, Randy was put on the city council. And for mayor, they appointed somebody who'd won a council seat who was a member of Teresa Ferguson's group, Concerned Citizens, who had vowed forceful and immediate action against undocumented immigrants, named Lindsey Lyons-- a business owner who runs the Arby's on the big highway through town. Soon after he took office, he talked about his plans to tackle the way the city looked, schools, uninsured drivers--
相反，Randy被安排进了市议会。至于市长，他们任命了一位赢得了议员席位的人，他是Teresa Ferguson所在的“关注市民”组织的成员，曾誓言要针对无证移民采取有力且迅速的行动，名叫Lindsey Lyons——一位经营高速公路上Arby's快餐店的店主。他上任后不久，谈到了处理城市外观、学校、无保险司机的计划——
The crime, the drugs, all the automobile accidents, and so forth.
犯罪、毒品、所有汽车事故等等。
This is an interview he did with Birmingham News.
这是他接受《伯明翰新闻》采访的内容。
For the most part, the majority of the people here are caring, loving people. But on the other hand, illegal is illegal. And we have no choice but to enforce what laws we have and not just bend the rules because we're asked to bend the rules.
大多数情况下，这里的大多数人都是有爱心、充满爱意的人。但另一方面，非法就是非法。除了执行我们现有的法律，不因为有人要求我们违反规则就去破坏规则，我们别无选择。
From the start, he and Randy Amos locked horns and pretty much never stopped fighting. People picked sides. And Lyons sets the council on a divisive crusade targeting the Latino population.
从一开始，他和Randy Amos就针锋相对，几乎从未停止过争斗。人们选择了阵营。Lyons带领议会进行了一场旨在针对拉美裔人口的分裂运动。
They bar city contractors from hiring undocumented immigrants. They make English the official language of Albertville. They ban taco trucks, which leads to an uproar. 200 people pack a town hall meeting.
他们禁止城市承包商雇佣无证移民。他们将英语定为阿尔伯特维尔的官方语言。他们禁止塔可餐车，导致了轩然大波。200人挤满了市政厅会议。
Not everything passes, like the proposal to force Latino businesses to translate their signs into English, or their proposal that would fine anyone who keeps their Christmas lights up past January 31st, or anyone who has indoor furniture on their porch outdoors, or broken vehicles on their lawn. And then one of the hard-liners on the council turned for help to the national anti-immigration heavyweight we quoted at the top of the show-- an innovator from the very cutting edge of the movement.
并非所有提议都通过了，比如强制拉美裔企业将其标志翻译成英语的提议，或者 fines那些在1月31日之后继续挂圣诞彩灯的人，或者那些在室外门廊上放置室内家具的人，或者在草坪上放坏掉车辆的人。然后，议会中的强硬派之一转而向我们在节目开头引用的全国反移民重量级人物求助——一位来自运动最前沿的创新者。
Albertville city officials are continuing their quest in curbing illegal immigration. So they've enlisted the help of a nationally recognized attorney, Kris Kobach.
阿尔伯特维尔市官员正继续他们抑制非法移民的追求。所以他们寻求了一位全国知名的律师Kris Kobach的帮助。
He is the man when it comes to illegal immigration issues.
在非法移民问题上，他就是那个人。
Councilman Chuck Ellis says he's--
议员Chuck Ellis说他是……
Today, Kobach is an ally of President Trump's. He's the person who explained to Donald Trump how the US actually could make Mexico pay for a wall. He's the vice chair of the federal commission that the president set up to investigate voter fraud. But back in the 2000s, Kobach was traveling to cities around the country, helping them draft anti-immigration ordinances that tested the limits of what the law would allow. They targeted landlords who rented to undocumented immigrants and employers who hired them, hoping to create an environment where they just could not get jobs or housing anymore.
今天，Kobach是特朗普总统的盟友。他是向特朗普解释美国如何能让墨西哥真正为墙付费的人。他是总统设立的调查选民欺诈的联邦委员会副主席。但在2000年代，Kobach在全国各地旅行，帮助他们起草反移民条例，测试法律允许的极限。他们针对租房给无证移民的房东和雇佣他们的雇主，希望创造一个他们再也找不到工作或住房的环境。
Then they make the rational decision-- hey, wait. It's not worth it to be here anymore. I'm going to leave.
然后他们做出理性的决定——嘿，等等。在这里已经不值得了。我要离开。
This is Kobach in an Eagle Forum meeting in Alabama around this time.
这是Kobach在当时阿拉巴马州的一次“鹰派论坛”会议上的发言。
You don't have to round people up and bus them home. You give them incentives to go home by rationing down the probability that they will get a job.
你不必把人集结起来送回家。你通过减少他们获得工作的可能性，给他们回家的动机。
I'd emailed him. I don't know how I got his email address. It seemed like it was on a website or something.
我给他发了邮件。我不知道我是怎么得到他的电子邮件地址的。它好像是在某个网站上或者是其他地方。
This is Chuck Ellis, the mayor's closest ally on the council, also a member of Teresa Ferguson's group, Concerned Citizens.
这是Chuck Ellis，议会中市长最亲密的盟友，也是Teresa Ferguson“关注市民”组织的成员。
And I told him who I was. And he said that he had read about that before in couple of places. He wanted to know how he could help me. I stood right over there behind that chair, and we chatted. And he said, hey, look, I'll come out.
我告诉了他我是谁。他说他以前在几个地方读到过这个。他想知道他能怎么帮我。我就站在那把椅子后面，我们聊了聊。他说，嘿，看，我会过去。
The proposal was to hire Kobach to help them write a law that would fine employers who knowingly hired undocumented immigrants. This plan died when one of the moderates on the council, Diane McClendon, called another city that used Kobach-- Valley Park, Missouri. Kobach helped them write ordinances that targeted employers and landlords. The city passed the ordinances and immediately got sued by civil rights groups for being discriminatory and unconstitutional. This mired them for years in expensive and fruitless litigation. Diane talked to their lawyer.
该计划是聘请Kobach帮助他们起草一项法律，对知情雇佣无证移民的雇主进行罚款。这个计划在议会中的一位温和派 Diane McClendon 致电另一家使用过Kobach的城市——密苏里州Valley Park时破灭了。Kobach帮助他们起草了针对雇主和房东的条例。该市通过了这些条例，并立即因歧视性和违宪而遭到民权组织的起诉。这使他们陷入了长达数年的昂贵而无果的诉讼中。Diane与他们的律师谈过。
And I asked him what came out of it. He said it cost millions-- the city-- millions. And I said, would you recommend it? He said, absolutely not. He said, nothing is going to come of it. And he said, I would not recommend it.
我问他结果如何。他说这花了数百万——城市——数百万。我说，你会推荐这样做吗？他说，绝对不会。他说，什么结果都不会有。而且他说，我不会推荐它。
The council voted against hiring Kobach on a 3-2 vote. But Kobach found someone else to work with-- state senator Scott Beason, the guy leading the statewide fight against undocumented immigrants, the guy who created that commission to investigate the problem. In 2010, he and Kobach got their chance to do something major. For the first time in over 100 years, Republicans swept both Alabama houses and the governorship, which suddenly made it possible to pass sweeping new legislation targeting immigrants.
议会以3比2的投票否决了聘请Kobach。但Kobach找到了其他人合作——州参议员Scott Beason，那位领导全州对抗无证移民的人，那位设立委员会调查问题的人。2010年，他和Kobach得到了做点大事的机会。在100多年来首次，共和党横扫了阿拉巴马州两院和州长职位，这突然使通过针对移民的全面新立法成为可能。
Kobach helped Beason draft it. It was called HB 56, the Alabama Taxpayer and Citizen Protection Act.
Kobach帮助Beason起草了它。它被称为HB 56，即《阿拉巴马州纳税人和公民保护法案》。
And now to the crackdown on illegal immigration in Alabama. The state's new immigration law is considered one of the toughest in the country.
现在谈谈阿拉巴马州对非法移民的打击。该州的新移民法被认为是全国最严厉的法律之一。
So we came here to Albertville, Alabama.
所以我们来到了阿拉巴马州阿尔伯特维尔。
2011, Fox News. Alabama's new law, HB 56, was groundbreaking-- the most extreme anti-immigration state law ever passed, intended to make life in Alabama so unpleasant that people would self-deport. To accomplish this, they'd made it a criminal act for citizens to have all kinds of transactions with people that they knew or should know were undocumented-- to rent them a home or harbor them or transport them. It was illegal to give them a job. Most contracts with them were invalidated.
2011年，福克斯新闻。阿拉巴马州的新法律HB 56具有开创性——这是有史以来通过的最极端反移民州法，旨在让阿拉巴马州的生活变得如此令人不快，以至于人们会选择“自我驱逐”。为了实现这一目标，他们规定公民与他们知道或应该知道是无证移民的人进行各种交易——出租房屋、窝藏或运送他们——均构成犯罪。雇佣他们是非法的。与他们的多数合同被宣布无效。
Some public utilities refused to provide gas, electricity, or water without proof of status. Schools had to find out the immigration status of new students and report that information to the state. Police could detain anybody they even suspected might be in the country illegally. And to get the bill passed, Scott Beason says he definitely relied on Albertville.
一些公用事业公司拒绝在没有身份证明的情况下提供天然气、电力或水。学校必须查明新学生的移民身份，并将该信息报告给州政府。警方可以拘留任何他们怀疑非法居留的人。为了通过该法案，Scott Beason说他绝对依赖了阿尔伯特维尔。
Albertville did make a difference by being able to take some legislators there. Because some people lived in places that weren't impacted by illegal immigration. And they were buying into this story that, oh, it's really not a big deal, and we really don't have a problem here. So it was more to show that, look, there are some towns who are being impacted by illegal immigration. So they could really see it. So it was a reality.
阿尔伯特维尔确实通过带一些立法者去那里发挥了作用。因为有些人住的地方没受非法移民影响。他们相信那种说法，噢，这真的没什么大不了，我们这里真的没有问题。所以这更多是为了展示，看，有些城镇确实受到非法移民的影响。所以他们真的能看到。所以这是一个现实。
Teresa Ferguson organized tours of the worst problem spots-- she called it the show-and-tell-- for any politician who came to town. State senators, three gubernatorial candidates, the attorney general, a member of Congress-- she had talking points on index cards that she carried around in her purse at all times. She drove me to some of the spots.
Teresa Ferguson组织了对最严重问题点的参观——她称之为“展示与讲解”——给任何到镇上的政客。州参议员、三位州长候选人、司法部长、国会议员——她钱包里随身携带着写有讨论要点的索引卡。她开车带我去了一些地方。
But this is the trailer park I was telling you-- here in the back was a trailer used as a brothel.
但这就是我跟你说的那个拖车公园——这里后面曾有一个拖车被用作妓院。
We went to places there had been prostitution and drug busts.
我们去了曾发生过卖淫和毒品逮捕的地方。
I think this right here-- don't want to slow down very much. But you see--
我想就在这里——不想减速太多。但你看——
She invited her own state senator, Hinton Mitchem, who had once lived in Albertville, out on the show-and-tell. A police officer drove them around to see rundown trailer parks and places they'd made arrests. After half an hour, she says, the car returned.
她邀请了她自己的州参议员Hinton Mitchem，他曾经住过阿尔伯特维尔，参加了“展示与讲解”。一位警官开车带他们去看了破旧的拖车公园和他们进行逮捕的地方。半小时后，她说，车回来了。
And when they opened the door, Senator Mitchem looked like they had just beaten him with a stick. You know, he just was so sad. He said, I am so sorry. I did not know.
当他们打开门时，参议员Mitchem看起来像是刚被人用棍子打过一样。你知道，他就是那么难过。他说，我太抱歉了。我不知道。
So after Albertville helped get HB 56 passed, once it went into effect, when reporters looked for a place to see it in action, Albertville was the place they went to. Mayor Lindsey Lyons-- he was on Fox, CNN, NPR, and TV around the state. He told the Sand Mountain Reporter, quote, "People may not realize that Albertville had a large impact on this bill. Some of the ideas in the bill originated here in Albertville." Here he is being interviewed on NPR.
所以阿尔伯特维尔帮助通过HB 56后，一旦法案生效，当记者寻找可以观察其实际效果的地方时，阿尔伯特维尔就是他们去的地方。Lindsey Lyons市长——他上了福克斯、CNN、NPR和州内的电视。他告诉《Sand Mountain Reporter》说：“人们可能没意识到阿尔伯特维尔对该法案有很大的影响。法案中的一些想法源于阿尔伯特维尔。”这是他在NPR接受采访时的情形。
There's less traffic on our streets now. There's less activity in the Hispanic-owned businesses that are here in Albertville. So we can tell a noticeable difference already.
我们街道上的交通减少了。在这里阿尔伯特维尔的拉美裔拥有的企业活动减少了。所以我们已经能看出明显的不同。
Do you like what this has done to your town?
你喜欢这给你的小镇带来的变化吗？
I'll tell you why I support it, and why I'm grateful right now. We've got close to 4,000 people in Marshall County out of work. And one of our local poultry plants, Wayne Farms, just had a job fair recently. And we had hundreds of Americans apply for these jobs that, in the past, could not get the jobs, because they would hire the illegal workforce. OK? And that's what I'm proud of right now.
我告诉你我为什么要支持它，以及为什么我现在感到感激。在马歇尔县，我们有近4000人失业。我们当地的一家家禽工厂Wayne Farms最近刚举行了一次招聘会。我们有数百名美国人申请了这些工作，而在过去，他们无法得到这些工作，因为工厂雇佣的是非法劳动力。好吧？这就是我现在感到自豪的地方。
Lyons made this claim to lots of reporters. Tom Howell was head of HR at Wayne Farms in Albertville at the time.
Lyons向许多记者提出了这一说法。Tom Howell当时是阿尔伯特维尔Wayne Farms的人力资源主管。
And I have to admit that they shocked me. Because that's certainly not true. It had no impact.
我不得不承认他们让我感到震惊。因为那绝对不是真的。它没有任何影响。
Frank Singleton was and is the spokesperson for Wayne Farms. He says they lost 17 out of 850 workers.
Frank Singleton当时是，现在也是Wayne Farms的发言人。他说他们850名员工中流失了17人。
There were not hundreds of local people who suddenly showed up and got jobs at Wayne Farms as a result of any of those bills.
并没有数百名当地人因为任何那些法案而突然出现并得到了Wayne Farms的工作。
The real impact of HB 56 on Albertville was this. Some people moved away. A lot of people stayed home or stayed off the roads. One guy told us he gave people rides in the trunk of his car. Businesses that catered to Latino customers saw a big drop. And in just three days, the schools lost about 120 Latino kids out of 1,400, according to administrators.
HB 56对阿尔伯特维尔的真正影响是这样的。有些人搬走了。许多人待在家里或不敢上路。一个人告诉我们他把人载在汽车后备箱里。服务拉美裔客户的企业看到大幅下滑。据管理员说，仅仅在三天内，学校就流失了约120名拉美裔孩子，总数是1400名。
It was all of a sudden-- you know, bing, bang, boom.
这非常突然——你知道，砰、砰、砰。
This is the person in charge of outreach to Latino families for the school district, Judit Gay.
这是负责学区拉美裔家庭外联工作的人，Judit Gay。
Oh, that was a terrible week. I would see their parents come in, crying, and the teachers crying, and withdraw the children. And we would just look at each other and hug, and they would cry. And I mean, it was just a bad week.
哦，那是一个可怕的一周。我看着他们的父母进来，哭泣，老师们也哭了，撤回孩子。我们只是看着对方，拥抱，他们哭了。我的意思是，那只是糟糕的一周。
To lots of longtime residents in Albertville, it seemed like their town was constantly on television during this period-- that any time anybody did a story about HB 56, they'd come to Albertville and talk about how terrible the town was-- how, before the law, undocumented immigrants had ruined the city, stealing jobs, bringing in crime, drugs. Nathan Broadhurst was one of the moderates on the city council.
对于阿尔伯特维尔的许多长期居民来说，在这段时间里，他们的城镇似乎不断出现在电视上——每当有人做关于HB 56的报道时，他们就会来阿尔伯特维尔，谈论这个城镇有多糟糕——在法律通过前，无证移民如何毁了这个城市，抢走工作，引入犯罪、毒品。Nathan Broadhurst是市议会的温和派之一。
It was all negative. I mean, every way we were being portrayed was negative. I think that was totally counterproductive. It caused fear and distrust. And it's hard to build a community on that type of thing.
全都是负面的。我的意思是，我们被描绘成每一面都是负面的。我认为那是完全适得其反的。它导致了恐惧和不信任。而在那种基础上很难建立社区。
Act four-- The Numbers. So all the time in Albertville people would bring up the thing that's at the heart of the immigration issue for so many people. And that is-- the millions of people who are living in the country illegally, what's that cost taxpayers? Like, what's it cost them? And one of the things we were excited to investigate when we went to Alabama was to figure out, what is the real answer to that for this one town? Like, how much money was it?
第四幕——数字。所以一直以来在阿尔伯特维尔，人们都会提起那个处于移民问题核心的事情。那就是——数以百万计的人非法居留在国家，这对纳税人意味着什么成本？就像，那花了他们多少钱？我们去阿拉巴马州时很高兴调查的事情之一就是找出对这一个城镇的真实答案是什么？就像，那是多少钱？
Well, there are different ways to estimate this. And the National Academy of Sciences tried to convene as impartial and unbiased a look at the evidence as possible to come up with numbers for the whole country. They assembled 18 economists and demographers and sociologists from varying points of view to figure out, what do immigrants cost taxpayers? They issued their report last year.
嗯，有不同的方法来估计这个。国家科学院（National Academy of Sciences）试图召集尽可能公正、无偏见的证据审查，以得出全国的数字。他们召集了18位来自不同观点的经济学家、人口统计学家和社会学家来找出移民让纳税人付出了什么成本？他们去年发布了报告。
Kim Rueben served on the NAS committee. She's an economist at the Tax Policy Center at the Urban Institute and helped me sort through the findings. The 618-page report is dense with charts and tables. Rueben pointed out, if you're an undocumented worker in an Albertville poultry plant, you still have to present a social security number to get the job, and so you pretty much pay the same taxes as anybody.
Kim Rueben在NAS委员会任职。她是城市研究所税收政策中心的经济学家，帮助我梳理了这些发现。这份618页的报告充满了图表。Rueben指出，如果你是阿尔伯特维尔家禽工厂的无证工人，你依然必须出示社会保障号码才能得到这份工作，所以你几乎支付和任何人一样的税收。
So you are paying sales taxes on the things you buy. You're paying property taxes, either if you own your home or through the rent you're paying to your landlord. And depending on whether or not you're working with somebody else's documents, you're paying income taxes and social security taxes. You're just not receiving the benefits when you retire. That money is a big bonus for the federal government.
所以你支付购买商品的销售税。你在纳税，不管是你拥有自己的住房，还是通过付给房东的租金。而根据你是否使用他人的证件工作，你还要支付所得税和社会保障税。你只是在你退休时没有领到福利。这笔钱对联邦政府来说是一笔大奖金。
In 2010, for instance, the Social Security Administration estimates 13 billion went into the social security trust fund from undocumented workers. And only $1 billion was paid out to them. So again, an undocumented poultry worker in Albertville pays the same taxes as anybody and doesn't qualify for most government benefits. And what that means is that their biggest cost to government, Rueben says-- in fact, the one way they cost more than other people-- is schools.
例如，在2010年，社会保障局估计有130亿从无证工人那里流入社会保障信托基金。只有10亿支付给了他们。所以再次强调，阿尔伯特维尔的无证家禽工支付和任何人一样的税，却没资格领取多数政府福利。这意味着，政府面临的最大成本，Rueben说——实际上，他们比其他人多花钱的一种方式——是学校。
That's the big public service that they're using. Because they often have more kids than non-immigrant populations.
那是他们使用的巨大公共服务。因为他们通常比非移民人口有更多的孩子。
Contrary to whatever stereotypes are out there, it's not a lot more kids-- 3/4 of a child more per couple than non-immigrant families in Alabama. But what that means for school costs when you run the numbers-- and Kim Rueben and her colleague Erin Huffer dug into the data on Albertville school costs to do that for us-- is that non-Latino taxpayers in Albertville are paying $272 every year in local taxes to cover those extra kids that their immigrant neighbors are enrolling in the Albertville city school system.
与现有的任何刻板印象相反，并没有多出很多孩子——在阿拉巴马州，每对夫妇比非移民家庭多出3/4个孩子。但当你算这些账时，这意味着什么——Kim Rueben和她的同事Erin Huffer为我们挖掘了阿尔伯特维尔学校成本的数据来计算——那就是阿尔伯特维尔的非拉美裔纳税人每年支付272美元的地方税，以覆盖他们的移民邻居送入阿尔伯特维尔市学校系统的那些额外孩子。
Kim and Erin also researched food stamps for us. That's the Supplemental Nutrition Assistance Program or SNAP. For all the complaints that we heard in Albertville about how, in the grocery store, you see Latina mothers using food stamps-- Teresa Ferguson, at one point, drove me to the big Foodland store so that I could witness this myself-- here are the facts on food stamps.
Kim和Erin还为我们研究了食品券。那是“补充营养援助计划”（SNAP）。对于我们在阿尔伯特维尔听到的关于在杂货店看到拉美裔母亲使用食品券的所有抱怨——Teresa Ferguson有一次带我去了大型Foodland超市，这样我能亲眼见证——这是关于食品券的事实。
When Latino families moved into Albertville and the county that it's in-- Marshall County-- between 1990 and 2010, SNAP use did go up in Marshall County. Rueben says it doubled.
当拉美裔家庭在1990年到2010年间搬进阿尔伯特维尔及其所在的县——马歇尔县——时，SNAP的使用在马歇尔县确实上升了。Rueben说它翻了一倍。
From 8% to 16%.
从8%到16%。
But in the rest of Alabama, where there are hardly any immigrants, it went up way faster and way higher.
但在阿拉巴马州的其他地方，几乎没有移民，它上升得更快、更高。
From 11% to 26%.
从11%到26%。
So having more immigrants in Marshall County correlated with lower food stamp use, not higher, and fewer taxpayer dollars spent. But these individual spending programs don't get you to the big picture. And to get the big picture, I think that the most helpful chart in the huge National Academy of Sciences report is a table they call table 812.
所以马歇尔县移民更多与食品券使用率降低有关，而不是更高，且纳税人花掉的钱更少。但这些个人的支出项目并不能带给你全貌。为了看到全貌，我认为巨大的国家科学院报告中最有帮助的图表是他们称为表812的表格。
Table 812-- its premise is, it says, OK, a new immigrant arrives in America tomorrow. What is everything that person is going to cost government at every level over the course of their entire lifetime, including what their kids costs and their grandkids? And then what is everything they and their kids and their grandkids are going to pay in taxes over that same period?
表812——它的前提是，它说，好，一个新移民明天到达美国。在那个人的一生中，包括他们的孩子和孙子们的成本，在各个层面上总共要花费政府多少钱？然后他们和他们的孩子、孙子们在那段时间里又要缴纳多少税？
So this chart looks at everything-- all federal, state, and local taxes, all federal, state, and local government services over a person's lifetime-- 75 years. And what table 812 shows very clearly is that whether you get more from government or give more to government really depends on how educated you are. It shows that immigrants who have even a little bit of college pay in more than they take over the course of their lives. But immigrants like the ones in Albertville's poultry plants, who mostly do not have high school educations, they are the costliest to government.
所以这张图表着眼于一切——所有的联邦、州和地方税收，一个人一生中所有的联邦、州和地方政府服务——75年。而表812非常清楚地显示，你从政府那里得到的多还是贡献的多，确实取决于你的受教育程度。它显示，哪怕只有一点大学教育的移民，在其一生中支付的都比拿走的要多。但像阿尔伯特维尔家禽工厂那样的移民，他们大多没有高中学历，他们对政府来说是最昂贵的。
Even in the rosiest scenario in this table, they, and their kids, and their grandkids, cost the government money over the course of 75 years. The author of this table-- this is a demographer named Gretchen Donehower-- did a calculation for us that specifically would apply to the undocumented population in Albertville-- that is, poultry plant workers who don't have a high school education and also don't have legit social security numbers. So they probably won't be collecting social security or Medicare in their old age. Those workers will cost the government $21,000.
即使在这个表中最好的情况下，他们，以及他们的孩子和孙子们，在75年的过程中也是让政府花钱。这个表的作者——一位名叫Gretchen Donehower的人口统计学家——为我们做了一个专门适用于阿尔伯特维尔无证人口的计算——也就是没有高中学历、也没有合法社会保障号码的家禽工厂工人。所以他们可能在老年时不会领取社会保障或医疗保险。这些工人将花费政府21000美元。
So it's $21,000 over 75 years. That's what an undocumented immigrant in Albertville's chicken plants and their kids and grandkids cost federal, state, and local taxpayers over the course of the immigrant's entire life. Of course, how you think about that $21,000 depends on your values. Maybe you think that's worth it for the economic growth and whatever other contributions the immigrant and his family will make. Or maybe you don't.
所以是75年里21000美元。这就是阿尔伯特维尔鸡肉工厂的无证移民及其孩子和孙子们在移民整个一生中花费联邦、州和地方纳税人的钱。当然，你如何看待这21000美元取决于你的价值观。也许你认为为了经济增长和移民及其家庭将做出的任何其他贡献，这是值得的。或者你可能不这么认为。
But to put it that number in context, anyone in America who doesn't have a high school education is a net drain on government over the course of their lifetimes, on average. The NAS report includes data on this also. A native born American without a high school education will cost hundreds of thousands of dollars more than even a documented immigrant-- even somebody who collects old age benefits. If you didn't graduate high school, generally, you're just not earning enough to pay that much into the system.
但为了把这个数字放在背景中看，在美国任何没有高中学历的人，平均而言，在其一生中都是政府的净负担。NAS报告也包括了关于这一点的数据。一个没有高中学历的本土出生美国人，甚至比文档齐全的移民——甚至是领取养老金的人——要多花几十万美元。如果你没有高中毕业，通常情况下，你赚的钱不足以支付进入系统那么多税。
Act five-- Today. By 2012, just a year after the anti-immigrants state law HB 56 went into effect, everything in town reversed course-- all that anti-immigrant politicking. HB 56 was gutted. Key portions were found unconstitutional by the courts.
第五幕——今天。到了2012年，在反移民州法HB 56生效仅仅一年后，镇上的一切倒转了方向——所有那些反移民的政治活动。HB 56被掏空了。关键部分被法院裁定违宪。
The immigrant families who moved away from Albertville-- most moved back. In 2012, the mayor and the city council came up for election again. And--
从阿尔伯特维尔搬走的移民家庭——大多搬了回来。2012年，市长和市议会再次面临选举。而且——
Albertville voters hit the reset button last night. Not a single person elected in 2008 was voted back into office.
阿尔伯特维尔的选民昨晚按下了重置键。2008年选举产生的没有一个人再次当选。
The mayor and four councilpeople-- all out. The city council since then has not spent its time trying to figure out how to control or deport the town's Latino residents. In fact, at their meetings, immigration doesn't come up. A councilman told us they consciously keep it off the table.
市长和四名议员——全部出局。自那时起，市议会没有花时间去弄清楚如何控制或驱逐镇上的拉美裔居民。事实上，在他们的会议上，移民问题根本没有出现。一位议员告诉我们他们有意识地将其排除在讨论之外。
One sign of how things have changed is that the Trump administration is expanding the 287(g) program, which gives local police officers the power to do immigration enforcement, which Albertville sought for years. But they're not trying to get it anymore. Benny Womack, who was police chief during the most divisive years, said something we heard from a few people.
情况如何改变的一个迹象是，特朗普政府正在扩大287(g)计划，该计划给予当地警员进行移民执法的权力，这是阿尔伯特维尔多年来一直寻求的。但他们不再试图得到它了。Benny Womack，在分裂最严重的几年里担任警察局长，说了我们从几个人那里听到的话。
I would say during that time period that we've all talked about here was growing pains for the city in a lot of respects. The city was in culture shock. I don't think it is so much anymore.
我会说我们在这里谈论的那段时间对城市在很多方面来说都是成长的阵痛。城市正处于文化冲击之中。我想现在不那么严重了。
The current mayor told us the city is now following the example set by the Albertville schools. And this is the single most surprising thing we found in Albertville-- was how the schools handled such a big population of immigrants. During the years the city council was picking fights with the city's Latino residents, right across the street, at the offices of the Albertville city schools, they were taking the exact opposite approach-- trying to integrate them into the community.
现任市长告诉我们，城市现在正效仿阿尔伯特维尔学校设定的榜样。这是我们在阿尔伯特维尔发现的最令人惊讶的事情——学校处理如此庞大的移民人口的方式。在市议会与镇上拉美裔居民挑选斗争的几年里，就在街对面，在阿尔伯特维尔市学校的办公室里，他们采取了截然相反的方法——试图将他们融入社区。
And they did an exceptionally competent job of it. At the very beginning, in the early '90s, when they had just a handful of Latino students, they hired a person whose job was to advocate for them and to make sure the schools accommodated them. In 1996, the school started pre-K in one of the Latino trailer parks. They got a grant for teachers to visit the parts of Mexico their students came from to see the conditions they were used to learning in.
他们在这方面做得极其出色。在最开始，90年代初，当他们只有极少数拉美裔学生时，他们聘请了一个人，其工作是为他们辩护，并确保学校适应他们。1996年，学校开始在拉美裔拖车公园之一开设学前班。他们获得了一笔拨款，供老师访问学生们来自的墨西哥部分，看看他们习惯的学习条件。
At one point, the schools made the dramatic and difficult choice to stop pulling Latino kids out of class for separate language and other instruction. It took three or four years to fully put that into effect and retrain the teachers to completely include the Latino kids in their lessons. Today, the student population is nearly half Latino. And the Latino kids are integrated into the band, sports teams, activities, AP classes.
在某一时刻，学校做出了戏剧性且困难的选择，停止将拉美裔孩子拉出课堂去进行单独的语言和其他教学。这花了三四年时间才完全付诸实施，并重新培训老师，以完全将拉美裔孩子纳入他们的课程。今天，学生人口中近一半是拉美裔。而拉美裔孩子融入了乐队、运动队、活动、AP课程。
And we're going to take the arc sine of each of those to get the theta.
我们要取其中每一个的反正弦来得到θ。
This is a lab for AP physics. Four girls roll marbles down a slope and take measurements, three of them Latina. Right now, Latino kids make up 43% of the high school and about 1/3 of the students in AP classes-- so not fully representative quite yet but getting there.
这是一个AP物理实验室。四个女孩让弹珠滚下斜坡并进行测量，其中三个是拉美裔。现在，拉美裔孩子占高中的43%，约占AP课程学生的1/3——所以还不是完全具有代表性，但正在接近。
Our coworker, Lilly Sullivan, attended high school with pretty much the same demographics as Albertville High School, and she was always one of the few Latinas in honors classes. And she visited five AP classes in Albertville, including this one. And what she saw kind of blew her mind. Right, Lilly?
我们的同事Lilly Sullivan就读的高中人口统计与阿尔伯特维尔高中几乎相同，她是荣誉课程中少数的拉美裔之一。她访问了阿尔伯特维尔的五门AP课程，包括这一门。她看到的让她大吃一惊。对吧，Lilly？
Yeah. It was really great to see. I just couldn't have imagined this. This is Bessie Gaspar. She's a senior. She's 17. And she is in that lab group. She's pretty bookish-- glasses-wearing. And this is how she explains the social dynamic at school.
是的。看到这些真的很棒。我简直无法想象。这是Bessie Gaspar。她是高四学生。她17岁。她是那个实验小组的。她很书呆子气——戴眼镜。这就是她解释学校社会动态的方式。
Well, this is kind of like a small community. So everybody's grown up with each other and knows each other. So there's nothing, like, really tense.
嗯，这有点像一个小社区。所以每个人都是一起长大，互相认识。所以没什么……真的紧张的东西。
Bessie's dad came to Albertville to work in a chicken plant. So I know her mom's, like, migrant farmworker family. And so when I asked her-- you know, she's doing all these activities, and she's just rattling them off.
Bessie的父亲来到阿尔伯特维尔在鸡肉工厂工作。所以我知道她妈妈像……移民农场工人家庭。所以当我问她时——你知道，她正在做所有这些活动，她只是在喋喋不休地列举它们。
Clubs-- like, I'm president of HOSA. I'm the vice president of FBLA. (LAUGHING) I'm on the soccer team. HOSA is Health Occupation Students of America.
社团——比如，我是HOSA的主席。我是FBLA的副主席。[笑] 我在足球队。HOSA是美国健康职业学生协会。
And I was just like, how did you know how to do this? How did you know about these programs and stuff? And then she just says, like, oh, well, I had this one teacher freshman year who pulled me into this club and another teacher pulled me into this club.
我当时就想，你怎么知道怎么做这个？你怎么知道这些项目之类的东西？然后她只是说，噢，嗯，我高一有一位老师把我拉进这个社团，另一位老师把我拉进那个社团。
We had Mr. Bolding. He knew my dream of becoming a neurosurgeon, because I had admired Dr. Benjamin Carson for his surgery on the conjoined twins. And so he told me about HOSA. And so I joined.
我们有Bolding先生。他知道我想成为神经外科医生的梦想，因为我很钦佩Benjamin Carson博士为连体双胞胎所做的手术。所以他告诉我HOSA。所以我加入了。
And I was like, oh. There was no way she was going to slip through the cracks, you know? It was just obvious that, you know, she's a Latina, and her teachers still had really high expectations of her. And they just expected her to do well. And so she did.
我当时就想，噢。她绝无可能从缝隙中溜走，你知道吗？显而易见，你知道，她是拉美裔，而她的老师们对她仍有很高的期望。他们只是期望她做得好。所以她做到了。
To be clear, the school has not eliminated the achievement gap between the Latino kids and the non-Latino kids. When kids enter a school system not speaking much English, that's notoriously difficult. And part of the gap is more about poverty than ethnicity.
需要明确的是，学校并没有消除拉美裔孩子和非拉美裔孩子之间的成就差距。当孩子进入一个不说太多英语的学校系统时，这是众所周知的困难。而差距的一部分更多是关于贫困而不是种族。
But a statewide expert on testing in Alabama, Tom Spencer of the Public Affairs Research Council of Alabama in Birmingham, explained to me that Albertville's student population is one of the poorest in the state. But each year, a higher proportion of their kids meet state standards.
但阿拉巴马州测试方面的全州专家，来自伯明翰阿拉巴马州公共事务研究委员会的Tom Spencer向我解释说，阿尔伯特维尔的学生人口是州内最贫困的人口之一。但每年，有更高比例的孩子达到州标准。
And when you put it in the context of poverty, they outscore where they'd be projected to score. They're actually significantly exceeding. And then when you get to the fact that they have a 95% graduation rate for Hispanics--
当你把它放在贫困的背景下时，他们超出了他们预期得分的水平。他们实际上显著超出。然后当你谈到他们为拉美裔实现了95%的毕业率时——
That's actually a higher rate than the white kids, who are only 92%.
这实际上比白人孩子要高，白人只有92%。
--they actually produced-- Albertville High School produced more Hispanic high school graduates than any other school in the state.
——他们实际上生产了——阿尔伯特维尔高中生产的拉美裔高中毕业生比州内任何其他学校都多。
And so what's that say to you?
所以这说明了什么？
It says to me that they're doing something right up there-- that they're closing gaps, and they're doing something impressive.
这说明他们在那边做了一些正确的事情——他们在缩小差距，并且他们在做一些令人印象深刻的事情。
So in this town where things got really ugly and heated for a while, the schools were a countervailing force-- the one place where people actually got to know one another. We met white parents who said their kids made friends, or they volunteered at the schools, and it changed how they viewed immigrants.
所以在这个曾经变得非常丑陋和激烈的城镇里，学校是一种平衡力量——人们真正了解彼此的唯一地方。我们见到了白人父母，他们说他们的孩子交了朋友，或者他们在学校做志愿者，这改变了他们看待移民的方式。
As for their Latino neighbors, I talked to lots of them about what it feels like in town right now. And mostly people said, I'm comfortable here. I made a life here. I like it.
至于他们的拉美裔邻居，我和他们中的许多人谈过现在在镇上的感觉。大多数人说，我在这里很舒服。我在这里生活。我喜欢它。
People own homes, are settled into neighborhoods, have white friends. But that's not the same as feeling welcome, especially in the last two years, they say, with the rise of Donald Trump. Marshall County went for Donald Trump 83%-- and by the way, 71% for Roy Moore this week. Carlos, who was in our first episode, says you see it most at the store.
人们拥有住房，在社区定居，有白人朋友。但那并不等同于感到受欢迎，特别是在过去两年，他们说，随着特朗普的崛起。马歇尔县83%的人投给了特朗普——顺便说一句，本周有71%的人投给了Roy Moore。Carlos，他在我们的第一集中出现过，说你在商店里最能感觉到这一点。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语对话]
Not so much with the younger generation, because they've gotten used to growing up around us, but with the older generation-- they look at us in a bad kind of way.
对于年轻一代没那么多，因为他们已经习惯了在我们身边长大，但对于老一代——他们以一种不好的方式看待我们。
As a school's migrant advocate, Judit Gay talks to lots of Latino families in town. And she summed up something I heard from a bunch of people. She says they don't care about trying to win over anyone who doesn't want them here.
作为学校的移民辩护人，Judit Gay与镇上的许多拉美裔家庭交谈。她总结了我从一群人那里听到的一些话。她说他们不在乎去争取任何不想要他们在这里的人。
Like saying, well, I got a job here, you know? I'm sorry. I got a job, and I'm going to do it until they want me here.
就像是说，嗯，我在这里有份工作，你知道吗？很抱歉。我有份工作，我打算做下去，直到他们想要我在这里。
Until they want me here?
直到他们想要我在这里？
That's what people used to say. Yes.
人们过去常那样说。是的。
In the beginning of our first program on Albertville, we had this quote from State Senator Scott Beason, the guy behind HB 56. He said back in 2011, if you allow illegal immigration to continue in your area, you will destroy yourself eventually. If you don't believe illegal immigration will destroy our community, go check out parts of Alabama around Albertville.
在我们关于阿尔伯特维尔的第一个节目的开头，我们有这段来自州参议员Scott Beason的引语，他是HB 56背后的那个人。他在2011年说，如果你允许非法移民继续在你的地区存在，你最终会自我毁灭。如果你不相信非法移民会摧毁我们的社区，去看看阿尔伯特维尔周围阿拉巴马州的部分地区。
But Albertville was not destroyed. In fact, by lots of measures, it's thriving, with Hispanic businesses all over town. Main Street's coming back, retail box stores moving in. Local sales tax revenues are on the rise. They just spent millions building a beautiful new high school, and they're in the middle of spending more millions on a big rec center.
但阿尔伯特维尔没有被摧毁。事实上，通过许多指标来看，它正在蓬勃发展，镇上到处都是拉美裔企业。主街正在回来，零售箱式商店搬进来。地方销售税收入正在上升。他们刚花了几百万建了一所漂亮的新高中，并且正在花费更多百万在大的休闲中心上。
As we reported last week, immigrants did not take jobs from American workers, but, apparently, created lots of jobs. We asked Scott Beason about how it all worked out.
正如我们上周报道的那样，移民没有抢走美国工人的工作，相反，显然创造了大量工作。我们问Scott Beason一切是如何演变的。
I'm glad that things are going well for them now. But I still believe that you can't just allow unbridled illegal immigration into one little town or whatever, even though things have turned out pretty positive for Albertville so many years later.
我很高兴他们现在情况不错。但我依然认为你不能仅仅允许肆无忌惮的非法移民进入一个小镇或什么的，尽管那么多年后事情对阿尔伯特维尔来说结果相当积极。
What do you think the lesson of the town is?
你认为这个城镇的教训是什么？
I think if we're going to learn anything, or I'd like something to be remembered about Albertville, it's that people in Alabama, people in Albertville, folks in the south-- they're good folks. And even when they have issues with an influx of folks who are from different countries or whatever, eventually, over time, we're very welcoming. But that would not make me want any other community to have to go through the same things that Albertville did just because 20 years later, well, it seems OK now.
我想如果我们能学到任何东西，或者我希望关于阿尔伯特维尔能被记住点什么，那就是阿拉巴马州的人，阿尔伯特维尔的人，南方的人们——他们是好人。即使当他们对来自不同国家的人涌入有异议时，最终，随着时间推移，我们是非常欢迎的。但这并不会让我想要任何其他社区不得不去经历阿尔伯特维尔所经历的事情，仅仅因为20年后，好吧，现在看起来还好。
Talking to over 100 people in town, it's not true the town was welcoming. It's more like they fought it at every level-- in the city council, at the state level with HB 56. And they failed. And only after they failed did they decide to take another path-- took a cue from the people who actually were welcoming-- the schools.
采访了镇上100多人，说小镇是欢迎的是不真实的。更像是他们在各个层面都在对抗它——在市议会、在HB 56州层面。而且他们失败了。只有在他们失败后，他们才决定采取另一条路径——从那些实际上是欢迎的人——学校那里得到了提示。
The anti-immigration activist Kris Kobach has said that in the 2000s, Alabama was a laboratory for the rest of the country and a model. And while the crackdown he and Jeff Sessions and others tried to engineer in the poultry towns around the state didn't pan out, they all moved on to try again-- this time from Washington, DC.
反移民活动家Kris Kobach曾说，在2000年代，阿拉巴马州是全国的实验室和一个模型。虽然他和杰夫·塞申斯以及其他人试图在全州家禽城镇进行设计的打击行动没成功，但他们全都转移到了再次尝试——这次是从华盛顿特区。
The woman who used to bring politicians into Albertville, Teresa Ferguson, told us she stopped organizing in town long ago. It's not needed now. Because, she said, their guy is in the White House. She's counting on him, she told us, to set things right.
那位曾经把政客带到阿尔伯特维尔的女性，Teresa Ferguson，告诉我们她很久以前就停止在镇上组织活动了。现在不需要了。因为，她说，他们的人在白宫。她告诉我们，她指望他能纠正事情。
[MARCHING BAND PLAYING]
[行进乐队演奏]
Ladies and gentlemen, the pride of Albertville, the Albertville High School Aggie band. They will be performing in the Rose Parade in California on New Year's Day.
女士们、先生们，阿尔伯特维尔的骄傲，阿尔伯特维尔高中Aggie乐队。他们将在新年那天在加利福尼亚的玫瑰游行中表演。
Today's program was produced and reported by Miki Meek, Lilly Sullivan, Diane Wu, and me. Our interpreter was Gabriella Munoz. Original music by Marcus Thorne Bagala.
今天的节目由Miki Meek、Lilly Sullivan、Diane Wu和我制作报道。我们的翻译是Gabriella Munoz。原声音乐由Marcus Thorne Bagala创作。
Our staff includes Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Kimberly Henderson, David Kestenbaum, Jonathan Menjivar, BA Parker, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our senior producer is Brian Reed.
我们的员工包括Susan Burton、Zoe Chace、Dana Chivvis、Sean Cole、Whitney Dangerfield、Neil Drumming、Stephanie Foo、Kimberly Henderson、David Kestenbaum、Jonathan Menjivar、BA Parker、Robyn Semien、Christopher Swetala、Matt Tierney和Julie Whitaker。我们的资深制作人是Brian Reed。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Tony Malatia. You know, he just saw the new Fast and Furious movie-- was not into it at all.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播电台通过PRX，公共广播交易所分发。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，Tony Malatia先生。你知道，他刚看了新的《速度与激情》电影——根本不喜欢。
They would just, like, drive around, like, without knowing absolutely anything-- totally like idiots.
他们就像是，开车到处转，就像，根本不知道绝对任何事情——完全就像白痴。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。